hey guys all the guys have seen my
sister Jenna hello now most of you guys
know that I'm pretty tech obsessed and
anything that Apple does I'm usually
pretty pumped about it Jenna on the
other hand what are you I'm like your
average consumer I would say if there's
a Candace new I thought I was like
alright I'll buy it
think about how much I do not want to
purchase the phone just because I'm like
I don't want to do it very differently
so you're an average consumer but you're
a little more of an advanced consumer
but I say you're a little more realistic
than I like I'm obsessed when people
call me an apple sheepman oh gosh we're
like we're like come on cheese beef
we're going to go over there Apple Store
are like this group we're talking about
the echo days today but something that
actually came up is the iPhone 8 hasn't
even came out they haven't even done i
phone 7's there haven't even been a
second edition over the iPhone 7 you
know how they usually do two different
phones yeah the news came out that they
have already started talking about the
iPhone 9 oh yeah can you believe me the
iPhone I let me show you wait what about
the eight I'm getting upset I or am I
getting excited I don't know
forget the iPhone eight rumors claim an
LG have signed an exclusive deal to make
batteries for Apple's iPhone nine so
does that mean we're skipping eight or
we're not skipping we're probably like
maybe six months away from when the
iPhone 8 will actually come on what six
months
wait what's today it's almost August
September Oh have you seen account and
heavy metals in your iCal where does
this year gone common I think it's going
to be six months anyway this is crazy no
real height the iPhone eight is real but
the fact that we're already talking
about the iPhone 90 come on god I've
never seen any iPhone 8 rumors I've
never seen anything I just I don't I
just stay away like like I don't like to
be excited about things I just I like
when I can physically oh I can hide
stuff since the iPhone 7 came out like
talking about the iPhone 8 like that's
just what we do this what we do she
doesn't get it I get it I like to be
real like okay I can have you actually
tomorrow then I'll talk about it Oh
iPhone 8 we confirm Apple's expensive
see my long expensive secrets for the
eclipse secrets a current iPhone 8
pricing from 1100 as production costs
are slightly higher than we originally
anticipated
this would be four hundred and fifty
dollars more than the entry-level
iPhones
I'm sorry LS $1600 for a phone
essentially well that the starting cost
would be $1,100 so if you wanted to get
the biggest one it would probably be
like two thousand meals I don't know for
sure I'm just reading what this this
text sent Oh sorry for celebutante could
be hiring one hundred oh we just had to
give reading yeah I would have
California is good yes so this a person
you're seeing something likely I've
actually never seen it I've never just
the vertical camera so there are
definitely going to be having the dual
cameras but most of the leaks that we've
seen is that this is this is what we're
going to have what do you think Joe um
what are you want me to think I'll save
it the first time that I saw this I was
like I'm not a big fan but now it's kind
of growing on me and yeah I'm a little
we make a difference as long as the
shots look good I'm not sure I don't
know I don't have an opinion not
surrender yeah it's going to be more
like the same yeah maybe it looks like
the Samsung so that lives in one of the
groomers they're going to have facial
recognition and one of the issues as you
can see here on this current render is
that there's no place for the home
button touch ID my so I'm gonna go
that's the question since you don't
really know much about anything right
now saying okay
you know a lot of things that you don't
know anything about the aqua neighbor I
heard that there was going to be no
Commission we facial recognition so like
the Samsung it has the touch ID on the
back but one of the things that you're
all betting on is will Apple put the
integrated touch ID in the front right
here right there well they will they
will then will you be able to touch the
glass I love it it's kind of cool though
when I just pick up my samsung and it
recognizes me is true don't have to do
anything but oh my god like what time
time your I'm like I don't want you know
you can't pull your father for you to
open it like it's trickle we've
definitely all seen this before I kind
of like it it's a queen well I'm me and
probably them very nice very futuristic
I was the future yeah nice so this seems
to be the number one render that
everyone is seeing this is on another
article here I think the iPhone bro is
potentially what its gonna be called and
it's in September in six months away
lipsticks weeks away how many weeks
until September is too much
so soon the colors we don't know what's
your speculation on there hasn't
circulations there might potentially be
chrome colors which that also is
probably could you imagine if I get up
from could you imagine if you like all
right $4,000 look this is some of these
vendors are also old like they're
nothing nothing bat and so look at this
I've seen this before it looks so good
look like a classic iPhone it's like it
looks like the galaxy there's a galaxy
head right next to it
yeah Champa thing it's going to be kind
of difficult to try to make the phone
look completely different because a
phone at the phone like what are you
going to do this completely different
have you seen the red phone yes no I
haven't actually I seen that it's a
thing but I didn't think they showed
pictures I thought okay you can
pre-order this no they did they showed
pictures and was crazy about it because
red is such a high-end camera company
like are they now going to be making
high-end phones and clearly starting
price it like a Levin hundred dollars
$1,200 but we're having at that exactly
but they have this thing where they're
going to be certainly seem like the Moto
the Moto phones that helps is modular
things you can just like add things on
to like a projector or speakers no I
don't I live in Iran if I can breathe
brands our other sister who knows
nothing about text but it's okay back
meow what else do we have Judy it's
going to be the same size in a little
probably the same size is it going to be
remember when I flick to shiny and the
matte so I'm at because the shiny one I
think I'll scratch super shiny super
shiny super slippery
how come it's 2017 and we can't make a
phone that stops just like slipping and
sliding right on my hand the red phone
has grips on the side of it almost kind
of crazy yep right there
I look it up what did you call me a
realist consumer consumer oh my god
$1,600 and what's cool about this is
they're calling it a holographic phone
too loudly so you had a noble health
antenna three yet when you held it up it
was like really D so they're talking
about holographic in the sense of it
having depth so if you're looking at
your phone you can like look inside your
phone and see more things
holographic what do you think about that
holographic picture of Maddie
yes
many there but seasonally here they're
like brand like brain can't look
comprehend it because I just do this is
real this is the real thing this is the
photo that bread shared so this does
grips here and you see this little thing
right yeah talking about like modular
things that you can attach so
potentially they could have lenses that
you can attach to this so it's an
extremely high and I liked it but it's
not that much more expensive than what
the speculated iPhones going to be
that's true Jenna so what do we do I get
the phone I anele anele let me know what
you guys think I would love to hear more
about which and I think of the red phone
from the little bits that we have heard
Smart has did an amazing video about his
thoughts and as you guys know he is by
far the biggest red fan I wish that I
could shoot on a red we get you to vlog
the other day on it which was super fun
but you can't do autofocus and at the
very impractical camera when you're
shooting by yourself
the marques does an absolute insane job
so I'm looking forward to seeing his
reviews of the red phone and I'm looking
forward to the new iPhone eight that
comes out not in six months you don't
even have to wait six months do mine can
you believe it I can't believe it do you
think will sleep out for it for those of
you guys who may not know this we slept
out full of fifty eight hours for the
iPhone 6 that was a thing we did do that
may I trust my calendar employ three
okay so I probably do it yeah outside
the Apple do it well thank you guys for
watching leave all of your comments
below and let us know we may think the
rumors anything else that you want to
say you want to go say hi to Jenna check
out her channel I don't think I'm going
to you
[Music]